I can't [ __ ] we're doing diplomatic
immunity okay anyone needs to know what
that is we near trying to find out who
is bring back the dragons and we're
going to sound more embassy because we
think it's down boys let's do this it's
this I've been looking for you got
something I'm supposed to deliver your
hands only [ __ ] let's see it as a museum
opening up in Dawnstar the owner is
asking me to hang out invitations to
travelers looks like that's it got to go
the [ __ ] out of my face you peasant
come on in let me know if you needed it
I don't think you were following by the
fire I have a plan yeah van stop teasing
me with that booty okay stop to use in
there but that booty the TV of that I
figured out how we're going to get you
into the town more embassy in your room
that would be a bad idea I'd be too
likely to attract the wrong kind of
attention to found more ambassador I can
get you into one of those I have a
contact inside the embassy his name is
mal born wood elf plenty of I'll get
word for him while you're doing that
I'll work on meet me at the solitude
stables that flew the range things with
melbourn ok any questions nope you talk
too much let's get out of here ok I'm a
man of few words ok man a few words
thank God fast travel man RS happy
[ __ ] upset the winking brown eye its
kind of sexual in it come on in let me
know if you need anything or take a seat
by the fire an awesome someone over mmm
really here's the deal I can smell don't
plan on bringing anything give me what
you can't live without and I'll make
sure to get it into the embassy rest
you're asking if you actually want to
get out alive I ok I'll get this inside
the embassy for you I've got to go I'll
find you at the party don't worry well I
mean right your job is to get into the
party without being fingered as a fine
I'll take care of the rest your job is
to get it without be ok better go to
staples
Kellis farmers like a hawk that
permission suit I don't know what has
gone on this side plenty prize wondering
while people are meeting on the process
of your hood another dragon attack
eventually have you given now born the
gear you want to smuggle into the
embassy yeah good but the only way
you're going which means when you're
ready you'll only have what mail bore
you can't go to work okay let me get on
my Potter's shoes attic says in the pas
de shou more embassy dress like that you
can't do [ __ ] oh [ __ ] park
okay yeah the man that's now I guess I
will have to do you should pass for a
real guests at least until you open your
mouth ready to board the carriage to the
embassy you about their bank don't worry
it would just make sure good luck [ __ ] I
forgot how hideous i am so it's a burger
a hamburger just a ham fellow late comer
drilling a little swore i am [ __ ]
arriving by carriage no makanya i salute
you sir my latest do getting lost on the
way up I prefer to arrive early often
the day before the party drink welcome
to the soul more embassy your invitation
please Avenged thank you sir go write it
now then here's my invitation I don't
have a poison deck welcome I don't
believe we've met i am ellen with the
foul more ambassador to skyrim and you
are Ellen Wednesday she's going to open
a bottle of the best firebrand running
later
hi please madam tell please help
yourself come on line of course not
you're going where do I had mentioned
kruky already arrest I told you before
not to bother me with such trifle do
enjoy yourself my apology we will have
to get better acquainted later please if
they take a mile for yourself what can I
get for you you made it in good as soon
as you distract the guards this door and
we can get you on your way oh you got
any what the store what is it so what
I'm doing is greatest racked up a hard
hours and trust me place better than
force relationships with the room and
shake thanks guys and the divine I hope
you're enjoying yourself sir what can I
get for you here you go sir Colombian
brandy Judea help yourself to me door oh
my god this is looking delicious he's
had the same problem then you lots of
wood is here
[Music]
[ __ ] my mate a head back up the baton
clothes are nothing more than an armed
mob [ __ ] locks anger you speak times
out mind if I dared any interesting
rumors of late have you visited warring
stately no matter how harsh the week I'm
sorry sir I'm on duty I came here hoping
to learn that more Imperial
reinforcements were on their way to
Skyrim but so far I've been disappointed
for now isodyne I hope I'm wrong well in
Ellen win I just wonder what the real
motivations are that woman is
inscrutable ok what is / have you tried
divine it's better than anything in the
blue palace what is wrong with yourself
I beg your pardon you must have me
mistaken for someone else lucky for you
I suggest there Ellen win spark but my
only regret is that she doesn't host
them more often what a good fellow need
them do ah if there's anything I can
ever do for you do not exceeding how
wonderful is that all Oh stand back and
behold of course she would never admit
captain safia is far too proud of
attention everyone could I have your
attention I am and now yes what do you
need of course I'll be waiting by the
door let's go before anyone noticed is
that ok nothing where's my gear likely
than that [ __ ] my gear we want her in
their bed although most of you are
already in bed with her but again so far
so good let's hope nobody saw we need to
pass through the kitchen your gear is
hidden in the larger
just stay close and let me do any talks
we've done it 40 stay close and let me
do any talking about an hour more follow
me I don't like strange nuts in my
kitchen a guest feeling ill leave the
poor wretch be a guest in the kitchen
you might want to tell your values rules
visit Sevani I didn't realize that
eating moon sugar was permitted perhaps
I should ask the Ambassador not appeal I
still not think you're in that chest
I'll lock the door behind you don't
screw this up come on if someone misses
me at the party we're both dead I got
the stuff
hurry it up good luck you guys robe
you're on your own [ __ ] is that
what am I supposed to go where I put the
[ __ ] go
okay [ __ ] let's go go Jason
Wow
alright
let's jump in right now meet me at the
shrine of Talos
okay more stuff is more stuff take over
here yeah item nice okay you got it
sister
[ __ ] do I get out of here listen up spy
you're trapped in here and we have your
accomplice surrender immediately or you
both die never mind silence trainer in a
canoe yes we still alive can't tell now
the foul more we'll be hunting me for
the rest of my life I hope it was worth
it it was ok let's get the [ __ ] out of
here [ __ ] there's the one groaning
and get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah Delphine and let's not tell her
what happened don't think we should tell
her that [ __ ] killer because that
would just kind of look badass and my
white [ __ ] come on in we got one food
warm drinks and warm bed she's sleeping
to go to watch over your bossman spread
ash done there made it out alive at
least your gear is safe in my room as
promised did you learn anything useful
really that seems hard to believe yes
apart figures of found one would be on
his trail though you mean aside from
wanting to kill it as burn was he knew
everything obsessed with it really
nobody ironic even so we do they know
where he is Rifton you'd better get
terrific oh just ask him where he was on
the CBS is profitable oh thank you